So quarantine fatigue is it's a real thing.
And when I talk about quarantine fatigue,
I'm not talking about the furious, gun toting
protesters that are demanding states be haphazardly
open back up, even when it's clear that states
can't be opened back up.
When I talk about quarantine fatigue like
an adult, I'm talking to the other adults
who have been doing what the public health
officials are telling us we have to do and
who may be experiencing different types of
quarantine fatigue.
This can be psychological.
This can be physical for people who are just
around less, moving around less.
And it can, of course, be economic.
Which we've been talking about as well.
The people in the Corona virus is a hoax.
This is government tyranny camp.
They're living in another world.
That's not who I'm trying to engage with here.
But I do think that it's completely reasonable
that by this point, if you're in one of the
states that is eight weeks into stay at home
orders, even even longer or close to it, in
any case, there is significant fatigue that
comes with self-isolation.
And the guidelines that we've been following
and I want to talk about a few different things.
One is, of course, what we're doing is to
flatten the curve.
And we understand that nobody's questioning
that piece.
And that's why we're doing it.
When we go out, we have to wear masks indoors.
And in places where you can't stay six feet
away from people, you're not supposed to see
friends and family that you don't live with
in many professions.
You're either working from home if you're
lucky, or you could be laid off or even permanently
fired.
Your business may have closed for good, but
people can only do it at 100 percent for so
long.
And the question is becoming, as people become
more fatigued, what should be done?
Clearly flipping a switch and going back to
the way things were would be a disaster.
And we would undo a lot of the progress that
we've actually made in the last four, six,
eight or even nine weeks that this has been
going on.
But maintaining things exactly as they have
been in the most closed states is starting
to approach an expiration date.
So what should be done?
There is a really good piece in the Atlantic
which explains if you just insist on keeping
everything as is keeping the strictest quarantine.
It's sort of like abstinence only sex education,
which we all know doesn't work.
It's not realistic.
It does not actually work.
The more reasonable thing would be to be clear
with people and have better, more detailed
guidelines about what people can do.
So let me talk about the all along stuff and
then the moving forward all along.
It would have been better to get federal guidance
on things that you should do.
For example, go outside for 15 minutes every
day.
A lot of people are not leet, not even stepping
out of the door, even if it's your front step
or your building's roof or a backyard, you
know, depending whether you're urban, rural,
whatever, just about everybody can step outside
for 15 minutes.
And every week we're learning more about the
connection between vitamin D and Corona virus.
We don't know that it's causal.
We see a correlation right now, but it certainly
won't help.
I'm sorry.
It certainly won't hurt.
If everybody gets 15 minutes of sun every
day, total vitamin D would be up, fewer people
would be deficient.
Mood improves with sunlight and outdoors and
risk is very low.
If you can't step outside without being six
feet away from people, then you've got to
wear a mask.
Great.
Would've been great to have clarity on that
earlier.
Most of the transmission is happening indoors
between people living together.
Then you have transmission at indoor workplaces
and health facilities.
Then you have transmission at indoor essential
businesses.
Right, like grocery stores, etc.
Very far down as transmission from people
outdoors.
Of course, if people are responsibly crowd
together on a narrow hiking trail, it's bad.
But the transmission happening outside from
people passing each other on bikes, this type
of stuff that that's been spreading as if
it's extremely dangerous.
It's not zero, but it is extraordinarily low.
And think of the good of people getting outside,
getting sunshine and hopefully doing some
exercise, walking around, etc..
Federal and state guidance on what are considered
low risk versus high risk activities would
be great.
For example, and New York is now doing this
tennis versus basketball, I think I don't
have to explain why there's a dramatic difference
there.
Also harm reduction tactics for people who
are determined that they are just going to
do high risk activities.
We are seeing that a lot of people just don't
listen to the guidelines in any other public
health venue.
We would provide harm reduction if you are
going to inject heroin.
We at least want to make sure you have a clean
needle so you're not spreading HIV if you
are going to be sexually active.
We prefer you do it safely and give people
access to contraceptives and sex education.
If you are going to absolutely be doing an
activity like this or that.
Here are the things you absolutely must do
to reduce the risk.
Now moving forward.
There are governors that are managing the
psychological component of this better than
others.
I'll give you an example.
Is New York ready to open?
Of course not.
The numbers are dramatically improved, but
the answer is they're not ready yet.
So what is Andrew Cuomo doing?
The governor there?
He announced three advancements, so to speak,
yesterday.
Number one.
So this is all starting Friday.
Landscaping and gardening businesses will
be allowed to open.
These are businesses where workers don't even
have to interact with customers.
It's outdoors.
This makes sense.
And it is businesses that get to open, some
people that get to go to work.
That's a good thing.
Outdoor low risk recreational activities like
tennis, again, being able to play tennis outdoors,
but not basketball.
It makes sense.
Everyone's really close together in basketball.
Not so in tennis.
And Andrew Carlo is going to open or allowed
to open drive in movie theaters, which, of
course, there aren't that many.
I don't think there's any in New York City,
but certainly a lot of New York state, most
most of New York state is relatively rural.
And I don't know the number of Drive-In theaters,
but it's an activity and it is something that
people can do.
This is the type of thing that should be done
now because it adds almost no risk, but it
builds capital because people feel like something
is going on.
Now, it only works if people do the things
they need to do when they are doing these
different things.
Charlie Baker here in Massachusetts yesterday
announced that they're going to announce some
first phase openings.
That could happen as soon as next week.
I assume it will be very minor, low risk stuff.
But again, the psychological benefit will
be very big.
Blue states are doing better at this than
red states.
In total, red states have been either doing
the stay at home order where people are rebelling
and it's imploding or doing nothing.
And the virus is spreading like wildfire,
that there actually is a middle ground here.
It involves very low risk activities, harm
reduction, making people aware that there
are things they could and even should be doing
that are going to be good for their mental
health and their physical health and get you
more buy in and allow people to behave safely
for a longer period of time.
Hopefully we'll see more governors do these
types of things